tonight i'm taking the f-word on the
road because it's the last week of my
competition to find the f-word's best
local restaurant
on tonight's first semi-final santa
maria del sur la san and sweet mandarin
all extraordinary contenders
at la san in birmingham i sample some of
the most sublime curry i've had outside
india that's exquisitely presented
finesse but akhtar islam was cocky and
argumentative has nothing to do with
flavor
well ultimately it's edible and it will
add to it but it's not the core of it if
you move it away you're not going to
lose anything the only thing to match
his immense ego was his talent i'm
looking forward to lifting that trophy
in contrast at santa maria del sur i was
bowled over by the warmth and charm of
manager jose
from argentina and the passion of head
chef ernesto
and i've tasted some of the best egg
i've ever eaten
yeah amazing i mean really good
and sweet mandarin in manchester served
at some stunning authentic chinese
cuisine it's a fabulous family business
run by twin sisters
[Music]
[Laughter]
i've got to pick the very best
restaurant how by setting them all three
very tough challenges
for the first test i've hired a team of
food experts to work undercover for me
as secret diners good evening have a
reservation under the name of duncan
it's a trick of the western trade i use
all the time i spend a fortune on secret
diners coming to all my restaurants it's
a really good way to see how consistent
a restaurant is on a daily basis
can i have the slow cooked lamb
i'm sending my secret diners to all
three restaurants who have no idea
they've been filmed
i have to find out how the restaurants
perform when they're not in the
spotlight and their guard is down
whichever restaurant fails to impress me
on this test will be eliminated
first up lasan
this stylish urban restaurant prides
itself on cutting edge and contemporary
cuisine
for birmingham we were the first
restaurant to break away from the
mainstream
when i visited la san i thought the food
was fantastic but the service was slow
i hope my secret dino is taken care of
today by the staff
oh thank you
i've asked kate blindman to go
undercover today because she's an
experienced food editor
[Music]
so he sits down the gentleman and lets
the lady sit down on her own
there's not that many there's so many
waiters around so it's quite hard to
grab somebody or if they are they're
collecting plates
i've told kate to act like a very fussy
diner with delicate taste buds
is it possible to change it because it's
a bit too hot for me sorry
could do with a little bit more of a
smile on there not look so miserable
oh thank you
finally smile should be at the beginning
not at the end very sweet of him
actually he said if i don't like this
one he'll replace it again so that's
really good the only thing i could be
worried about
with last hand service that was
attentive halfway through not at the
very beginning it's
a little bit fragmented and service
needs to gel
next up sweet mandarin in manchester's
northern quarter
the express lunch looks like it's really
good value
it's run by twins who are the third
generation of women in a chinese cooking
dynasty established by their grandmother
[Music]
the sisters don't have a clue that
they're going to be assessed by my
undercover observer
[Music]
i've hired cheryl farmer because she's
got nearly 20 years experience in the
food industry and i've instructed her to
order off the menu to see if the chef is
willing to be flexible
do you do a squid that hasn't got a
batter
[Music]
without the batter
is that possible okay lovely thank
that lady she's you one of the owners
essentially because she needed to please
and uh everything's possible
yeah food sort of
heaped and dumped on a plate no finesse
it's nice but it's just not hot enough i
like it i like my food really piping hot
i'm trying to get retention but the
waitress has wandered up to her out of
high shots
in fact the restaurant's been abandoned
by our staff i think
the one positive part is that it's run
by two sisters and they're great girls
they're warm they're funny and they're
charismatic but there was must've been
an off day when a restaurant's family
run then it needs to feel family run
they need to
be a lot more friendlier
so will santa maria del sur do any
better
open five years ago santa maria is
vibrant and lively the restaurant
radiates warmth and friendliness
[Music]
my secret diner is on the way and the
fun-loving brigade from battersea
have no idea
[Music]
i've only got an hour to eat is that
okay is that going to be okay
rob allison regularly works on
best-selling recipe books it's a bit
light in here really yeah but lighter
than i actually um
[Music]
i'd say that the
filling could do with a bit of seasoning
but um
pastry is spot on there absolutely spot
on literally we're just halfway through
our starters and they've just started
lighting the candles and
i think they're like yeah is at the
lights going down yeah the light's going
down a little bit if you're open at 6 30
then you have you ready at 6 15. so the
minute that first custom wall store
everything's there candles are there and
uses the atmosphere smell of the grills
there i think for my main course i'll
have i'm going to go vegetarian i'm
afraid i'm going to go with the
mushrooms
i've asked rob to be deliberately
indecisive to see how the team cope
you know what yes i'm gonna be really
annoying
i've just seen my friends steaks
i really want a steak
thank you very much
they have dealt with that
impeccably i would have actually
probably kicked my own head in had i
done that slightly slow start picked up
in the middle and then when he changed
his mind about the dish they really
warmed him in a big way so yeah great
comeback
so it's time to eliminate one of the
restaurants
my decision is based on everything i've
seen and learned so far
including hours of invaluable undercover
evidence
[Music]
no one has any idea i've been spying on
them
but i have told them that one restaurant
is about to be knocked out of the
competition
when you're on a roller coaster just
it's just reached the top and it's just
stops for a second doesn't it and it's
that feeling and it's been going on for
about a week now so i i do want the ride
to carry on we haven't slept for the
last few days just being very nervous
waiting for today it's important result
for my life for my for my restaurant and
for cindy as well for everyone you know
[Music]
santa jose gordon how are you oh very
nervous man very nervous waiting for you
for the answer now the secret of any
good local restaurant is attentive
service good food recently okay we've
had the f word secret diners in the
santa maria restaurant on the feedback
and the
insight to what the f-word secret diners
gave me
in terms of their experience
yes
santa maria
oh my god
congratulations really well done
[Applause]
[Music]
it's great something amazing for me
my boss cynthia i'm a little one
every every everyone is happy today i
think it's one of the most important
moments of my life
santa maria have done amazingly well and
now they have a chance to win a place in
the final
oh my god
welcome back it's the semi-final of my
best local restaurant competition and
three teams are fighting for a place in
the final only one will go through
so far tonight's first semi-final my
best local indian chinese and
argentinian restaurants have been put to
the test
good evening have a reservation i sent
in a team of secret diners to
investigate the contenders
there's so many ways around so it's
quite hard to grab somebody
and santa maria passed with flying
colours they're still in the running
congratulations
but now i have to eliminate one of the
remaining two restaurants
who will be going out of the competition
la san or suite mandarin
every call i think everyone's just gonna
be looking at the phone today is very
important for us it really is the make
or break
good afternoon lasagna speaking i might
help you
hello swandran
we've had
secret diners in the dining room
i've had the f word secret diners um
eating a sweet mandarin recently i've
learned a hell of a lot and i've seen
some fascinating things
the feedback's been extraordinary um the
value of the
set lunch menu um is amazing whilst i
like your confidence there's a cockiness
that has to be contained
so
the name of the game is consistency and
that has to be so apparent across the
board
[Music]
sweet mandarin
i'm really sorry the f-word secret
diners were somewhat let down the
food
wasn't up to scratch there was also
complaints in terms of service being
uninterested
so i'm really sorry
thank you ladies of course we're
disappointed because we've gone so far
into the competition you're in a losing
life don't you
we're a winner because we have won the
best chinese restaurant did i mean
really good
fantastic work great feedback from the
secret diners incredibly happy very
consistent congratulations
[Applause]
well done
[Applause]
that's a lot of words because never
experienced anything like this it's just
absolutely amazing i mean the feeling
is is is definitely there and i mean
obviously with reference to my cocky
natures you know it's just the way it is
so i've chosen santa maria from south
london to fight out with lasan from
birmingham
to be worthy of a place in the final
they have to survive two more challenges
[Music]
[Applause]
first i've asked 30 f-word diners to
tesla san and santa maria to breaking
point
and i'm gonna judge both restaurants
performance more critically than ever
before
we're going to have lunch at la san
and then dinner at santa maria
ladies and gentlemen good morning really
good to see you you're going to be my
eyes and ears across the whole dining
room
your experience is going to help me
judge which restaurants go through to
the final of the f words best local
restaurant
with lassan under intense pressure i'm
going to watch like a hawk front of
house and behind the scenes in the
kitchen
i'm expecting to wow everyone you know
dazzle and delight i'm you know
confident we'll uh do well because it's
our own kitchen and something that we
you know we're working every day and
food that we do all the time so you know
nothing's alien to us so i think we'll
be good
[Applause]
hi guys hi ladies how are you all i'm
very little chef how are you yeah
veronique thank you good to see you
right
this is it real pressure you performed
brilliantly in the f-word restaurant now
i want to see what you like in your own
ration under immense pressure
two hours two courses 30 diners
yes it's not just the food the service
have you got what it takes to get into
the final yeah this
today okay will help me judge you guys
under pressure i'll be upstairs
downstairs in and out in and out good
luck thank you two hours starting from
now off you go guys yes
[Applause]
[Music]
i know this is every restaurant's worst
nightmare thirty diners arriving all at
once
but i need to test the team to the limit
if actor harmony staff support each
other today it should run like clockwork
but i can tell straight away that the
auditing system is far too complicated
so each waiter takes an order then puts
in the computer
just forwards you back to touch you will
enter the order so that's very difficult
that isn't it because if he's entering
the computer
and they're taking the order
if he makes a mistake then it's already
going to two different people before he
gets to the kitchen
the orders taken by the waiters are
given to the maitre d who puts them into
the computer in the dining room upstairs
then they're supposed to be printed out
in the kitchen which is downstairs
okay gentlemen here it goes you've got
one lemon sole one afghani lamb get the
lamb in straight away please let me
still hold that back for a second we've
got two courses missing on table 11's
order complicated ordinance system they
take the order then it goes into another
waiter's hand yep then it goes to the
computer you just said there's two
courses missing why doesn't one waiter
take an order come to the computer
complete it without passing on to
somebody else
the reason why i'm in the i'm with the
ordering system the we've got quite an
old sister just to make your life easier
so i'm just asking from a chef's point
of view if i don't feel comfortable i
come down and ask you and i want to know
your reason that's all that's cool
with 30 customers to look after at the
same time akhtar's ordering system can't
cope and my diners are now eating
different courses
it looks bad for customers eating their
main course when other cousins haven't
had their starter for me it's like a
regular card operation it was not all a
la carte so don't [ __ ] me that way
what i'm trying to say is that if i'm
sat here and i'm waiting for my starter
and i'm still waiting for my starter and
then the next table's main course has
come i'm going to feel a little bit
pissed off that's what i'm trying to
tell you okay don't waffle me yes thank
you
and the waiting times are just far too
long
how long have you waited for your main
courses you only shared a starter yeah
how long are we waiting for the main
courses roughly
yeah yeah i've got it down at 35 minutes
35 minutes is far too long okay thank
you uh how long for that main course
please i think the customer needs to
know
how much longer can you give me a time
16 yeah that's towards the end you want
that first give me a time for someone
that's gonna be eight ten minutes at
least ten minutes at least actor he's
gotta get a grip get hold of the reins
and really sort of start pushing this
food out but you know kitchens just
don't run normally they need generating
you've got to push them all the time so
there's a customer sat upstairs
minus the main course which is not good
when actors food does make it to my
diners they think it's absolutely
delicious
really really really good very complex
a lot of really powerful flavors going
on
so it's good
but the curry isn't everyone's taste
did the customer say anything when we
clear this away because those are
painting the sauce a bit too much
sometimes okay is anyone telling the
chef i think the chef says that as a
signature so he kills uh he needs to
have quite a lot of sausages i know it's
a signature dish it doesn't stop him
from making it less spicy does it it
doesn't know it's like everyone's scared
to tell the chef what's happening does
anyone give constructive feedback to the
chef downstairs or not
no
if this was my restaurant okay i'd be
deeply concerned that food like that is
coming back why is that not eaten and
why is all this sauce still there is
there an issue customers not happy
surely you'd want to know
yes that's all this is a signature dish
this is something that
means a lot to the restaurant yet no
one's saying anything
if the waiters can't give actor honest
feedback on his dishes that's a serious
problem
actuaries gordon
so chef having a quick taste of the
mcmahony sauce that they're saying
they're saying is a little bit too spicy
okay
that there's only two tables that's all
just a touch of yoga but there's another
table that have been cleared and
two-thirds of the dish hasn't been eaten
so two plus two is four there's only 30
of my diners here it's not as if there's
120 people sat up here
the food in the restaurant was excellent
so on that basis i think i'd you know
definitely come back and give it another
try
so my 30 diners definitely enjoyed their
lunch but there is room for improvement
right
uh well done i tasted every dish
i thought the food was outstanding
how'd you find the mutty chef
i thought the food was outstanding
absolutely delicious doesn't need
go finish
sorry
sorry however
when customers don't
finish
two-thirds of their plate i think you
should see what's going on i don't think
food should be washed down to the bin
and plates stuck in the dishwasher i
think that should come back down to the
kitchen because that gives you feedback
we
started off good in the kitchen but
upstairs was somewhat
at many stages embarrassing the service
was erratic order's been taken main
course had been missed off i'm looking
for a restaurant
to win
the f words best local ration on an
overall experience
i thought the food was delicious
i thought the service was mediocre
um
right now you know um
i see a bit disappointed that you know
we didn't uh
you know delight chef ramsay on all all
points of dining experience could have
been better but you know the fact is you
know we've made it so far and he did say
he's got something up his sleeve for the
next challenge so i'm looking forward to
that now
next stop dinner at the argentine grill
house in south london
when i first visited santa maria they
served me some of the best steak i've
ever had
so i hope even under pressure from my 30
f-word diners round two here we go
they're going to maintain their
excellent standards
and and yes right navy tonight
silence are coming
really soon i'm always trying to relax
him because he's nervous hola
how are you you're right it's fine thank
you
this is gonna be a big test on tonight
30 diners arriving all at the same time
will they manage on the grill will they
manage the service will it be fast slow
i want to see what they're like with me
watching them in their own environment
good to see you guys yeah and first of
all congratulations uh really well done
now is where it really is gonna be
immense pressure now real dinos
in your restaurant yeah
that really know their food so i wanna
see it running under immense pressure
like a normal fully booked restaurant
yeah make sure that everything you send
out the kitchen you're 100 happy with
because they are critical okay
two hours
start from now good luck off we go
i remember it's not a racer not a
friendship quality who's cooking in the
kitchen now just two of you yesterday
yes wow yeah come on go on
okay we have the first table stable
number three one more massage one
freelancer one two one miss andrea
and two united states
santa maria are quick off the mark but
their starters are all going out at once
they need to stagger the orders and pace
themselves you normally send the
starters that quickly you don't waste
your steaks are on first before you
understand or you just send the salad
straight away guess what's up okay
because they're quite thick those
fillets yes
quite thick they've only been here in
literally 50 minutes first order taken
within five minutes already the food
coming out good start very good start my
big worry if ernesto gets 30 different
steaks on that grill going away all the
same time different temperatures rare
medium medium well that's gonna be a big
test for him in about 45 minutes time i
hope he doesn't crack
so far my diners are having a lovely
time
just from sort of the first moment we've
walked in really really friendly staff
the waiters came over introduced
themselves they've chatted to us they've
you know had a bit of a laugh with us
but having served the starter
simultaneously ernesto is now under
pressure to have 30 main courses ready
exactly the same time as well
number one after the table number five
please tune is ready on that table there
yes surely the main calls you serve at
the same time
they're not eating that's all they're
leaving it good to go cold
sorry for the slightly delay guys it's
coming the steak right now
hopefully we will make it up with a
steak
the only the only thing is when you have
all the people asking at the same time i
know no no no no that's what i said you
must be yourself don't send the starters
so quickly so sadly
there's not such a long gap between the
main course and the start yeah that's i
think you think that's a good point to
speak afterwards
let me speak with you guys
there's an atmosphere that's high and
it's electric which is great sounds
brilliant but they just shouldn't rush
food out there take their time pace
yourself a little bit more the starter
came very quickly within a few moments
um following that after five ten minutes
the main cause
it's all very very fast
as if they want to turn the tables for
another first people
that's really good because it melts yeah
that is awesome
we've all been here just over an hour
and already the last orders have been
cooked
it's the last one yes it's the last one
[Music]
the team have worked so well together
that they're finished with 40 minutes
left on the clock
it was it was really really good very
enjoyable good taste it was
perfect and
absolutely melted in your mouth it's
probably the best steak i've ever tasted
actually i had philips steak as my main
course which was absolutely superb i
can't fault it at all okay
right
first of all well done i thought you
handled it very well i thought the food
you know
looked and tasted immaculate i thought
the service was very friendly and very
charming yeah
if there's one criticism tonight it's
not a race you finish with just over 40
minutes left
there's only 30 customers in there not
130 customers and every table yeah it's
a value table they're here for an
experience the overall package don't
rush
well done
job well done
good night
thank you
we tried to make a great job tonight
with
with love
the passion
try to make wonderful food tonight santa
maria grill is gonna be a tough one to
beat because there's a whole package
there and it's it's done to perfection
watching ernesto work on that grill i
mean it's amazing i mean talk about
multitask it's like an octopus with like
10 arms
and more importantly above everything
everything they touch is about passion
[Music]
we've had a day of extraordinary dining
at two incredible restaurants but one of
them will be eliminated
the biggest test is still in front of
them who's going through the final right
now i haven't got a clue welcome back to
the f-word la san and santa maria are
fighting out for a place in the final
tonight two semi-finalists have already
faced two daunting tests
under pressure in their own restaurants
i'm seeing their true colours
no no [ __ ] ups today
lassan 29 year old actor has proved
fearless in the kitchen one lemon soul
one afghani lamb get the lamb straight
away please let me show hold that back
for a second
he pushes colony boundaries and lasan's
original distinctive menu reflects his
passion for innovation i thought the
food was outstanding
but he risked over complicating the food
trying too hard he has an extraordinary
potential but he won't listen to advice
even from me if i don't feel comfortable
i come down and ask you and i want to
know your reason that's all so he misses
out on vital feedback
at santa maria ernesto la brava is a
master of his charcoal grill okay we
have the first table table number three
he times each state to perfection and
that takes talent
above everything everything they touch
it's about passion
when i'm worried that the menu an
unnested repertoire is a bit limited
he cooked sublimely within his comfort
zone and i'm already impressed but to
earn a place in the final he has to
dazzle me
[Music]
now both restaurants face the ultimate
challenge here at my own flagship
restaurant royal hospital road in london
ernesto must create and serve exquisite
cuisine worthy of a place on the menu at
my three michelin style restaurant
they're cooking one dish the most
important dish of their entire lives
and with that one dish they've got one
final chance to prove themselves
i am very very nervous to cook in this
restaurant because
he's the restaurant of
one of the best japan in the world
cooking
at chef ramsay's restaurant through
michelin's time and something that i've
always aspired to you know nevermind
three one would do for me and i'm
cooking the three michelin star kitchen
today
[Music]
i've worked for over 10 years to build
royal hospital road's reputation and
tonight i'm putting it on the line
i've invited some highly distinguished
guests including angela hartnett one of
the only female chefs in britain ever to
be awarded a michelin star
it's a huge challenge for these guys to
be cooking in this three-star restaurant
and then they've got gordon bearing down
on them so they're probably having a
nervous breakdown as we speak but you
know hey ho we're looking forward to
some food hopefully let's see if we get
some but yeah i wouldn't wish it on
anyone welcome to all hostel road good
to see you guys um this is it
on the back of today's performance
one of you will be going through to the
final
first time in 10 years i've ever handed
my restaurant over to any chef this is
my baby three mission stars everything
i've ever worked for in 25 years is
inside this restaurant it's got to be
absolutely perfect
this is the climax
one of you is going through to the final
good luck off you go
the teams are working one of the most
well equipped kitchens in britain with
the finest ingredients money can buy
i've challenged both chefs to create one
dish using the best quality english lamb
which i provided
it's incredibly flavoursome but a
challenging meat to cook perfectly
i know two gives away table six ernesto
yeah two lamb kebabs yeah chef thank you
cynthia
you can respond as well please
four covers away table one four loin of
lamb
hello yes sir thank you oh my god come
on guys
for his dish tonight akhtar has raised
the bar yet again
he's serving a roast smoked loin of lamb
on cauliflower and potato with a
caramelized onion and saffron gravy
it's incredibly ambitious with 44
ingredients the most complicated dish
currently on my menu here has only 19.
akhtar has marinated the loin lamb
overnight in traditional indian spices
he smokes the meat with charcoal before
searing it then bakes it for six to
eight minutes
akhtar blanches the cauliflower potato
base and fries it with herbs and spices
and then serves his dish with an onion
and saffron gravy
if akhtar doesn't blend the spices with
perfect precision he'll ruin the entire
dish
to pull this off requires a level of
skill near genius
ultimately every uh competition has
winners and losers it's just that until
now i've never tasted what it feels like
to be the loser done
come on
we've always said you know there's only
one place for us and that is winning it
uh we didn't
say you know we'll you know we're having
hold this for me please um be careful
use a ladle because you're gonna burn my
hands so the idea behind the dish was
what we've got rajasthani style marinade
um which is
smoked with them cloves and then we've
got a mogul style gravy that's they
introduced the use of cashew nuts and
caramelised onion and that's served with
the
potatoes and
cauliflower which is cooked in a north
indian punjabi style with the fresh
fenugreek fenugreek and saffron for the
potatoes cauliflower no the saffron's
actually in the uh the gravy and the
gravy yeah that's right
the dish is a little bit too complicated
it's adventurous again i just hope this
time it doesn't come back to bite him on
the ass
very nice that looks lovely go please
let's go
[Music]
it's very spicy
[Music]
standard anyway so it's only fitting
that they're in just until
[Music]
in stark contrast to akhtar's dish
ernesto has chosen to work with just a
handful of flavours
i am living the dream i'm so so happy
today if we win that should be something
incredible for my life
it's a simple dish lamp kebab with a
potato salad and mint chutney
ernesto marinase's cube loin of lamb in
smoked paprika cumin coriander and
garlic
and then he threads it onto fresh steaks
of rosemary with red pepper and onion
he mixes purple and baby new potatoes
with a dressing of olive oil lemon juice
and creme fraiche and add sliced
radishes and herbs
the chutney is a simple mix of ginger
chili and mint
ernesto griddles his kebab until it's
charred on the outside
this is definitely the first time a
kebab has been served at royal hospital
road it's something i'd expect to see on
the menu at santa maria but today i'm
looking for a dish worthy of a three
michigan star restaurant
okay talk me through the dish because it
sounds a bit plain jane doesn't in terms
of boring yes kebab but it's not just an
average kebab it's a special kebab
especially with the rosemary stick
something natural what does the rosemary
do inside that lamb rosemary is amazing
i think rosemary lamb is the best
combination favorite so you've got mint
in the marinade and rosemary running
through the lamb yes so you think the
simplicity is this the best point yeah
and the grill will be the over
complicated yes over complicated we need
to find things easy to make right yes
put boom plate ready out next table and
i think that is keep dancing you know
today's about raising the bar
and taking a dish
to a different level to make it
absolutely exceptional has he got the
aspirations to go higher or is he going
to just stay in that mainstream grill
good that looks very simple but it looks
incredibly delicious simple go please
table five let's go thank you well done
now four more
[Music]
away thank you
quite strong on the garlic sauce
[Music]
that's lovely huh the sauce is delicious
if you
ask a footballer player where he would
like to play they would say wembley you
had someone to cook they would say
gordon ramsay kitchenman
this is the cathedral of cooking so
i think they are very nervous but i
think they will do it okay
what you get from santa maria is passion
through and through
there's no
there's no egos you know it's about them
as a team not about one individual and i
think more than anything this guy cooks
from the heart santa maria has all
connected bonded and it shows and yet
these two here there's no teamwork
there's no no support there you donkey i
told you to put a fresh two on that was
overcooked
are you two okay we're fine jeff we're
fine because it's not looking like the
most dynamic team together we're singing
off the same hymn sheet
generally it's like they couldn't be any
further apart that's how mistakes come
in
is that a bit hot for you you here is
that a bit hot for me i just tasted it i
thought it was
delicious but you've got this [ __ ]
thing that i've you know i
i think you're quite a talented guy
unfortunately cockiness rides over your
talent he just turned around and looked
at me and said is that a bit too hot for
you not in that way not us okay well why
am i supposed to take it you're not here
to blow smoke up my ass and secondly
more importantly i thought the dish was
delicious thank you but before you ram
it down my throat it's just nice to back
off a little bit and show a little bit
of humility i just thought
fine i'm allowed to have been i'm not
stopping you from allowing your thoughts
but there's a difference between
thinking and ramming down someone's
throat i just thought chef that you
found it quite uncomfortable what i was
trying to say at that point was not was
it too hard
it will it will cut once the cream goes
into it i guess that again i want to
taste the base before you finished it so
i can see it through different stages
seen how clever it is to get from that
the final dish
let the food do the talking
pipe down a little bit and put that big
mouth big boy attitude into your food
that will get you through the final how
long for the last two please
we'll be we're placing up now chef okay
great well done
good
so service is over and it's time to
discover the truth of my distinguished
guests
in terms of the curry dish today killed
by lassan how was that for you i find
extraordinary dish which is produced and
the taste and texture saffron sauce
beautifully blend super dish well
presented well garnish and i loved it
with this dish i think actor's done it
it is in the final four definitely in my
view
talking about the lam kebab how was that
particularly the sauce yes in terms of
the lamb kebab
and the uh lamko which one do you prefer
the lamb kebab
we happy with that very happy yeah yeah
good timing was great
food tasted great what was more
impressive than anything is how the team
works sean
well done thank you thank you
i am 100 happy in this great place this
amazing restaurant
he's a dream i am very very happy
everything was amazing very very good
how was that for you
um
it wasn't um
i wouldn't say it was the best service
of my life are we happy the dish
um yes uh it's totally happy what's
going on with the teamwork what happened
there
the team works out i mean the way we
communicate because obviously there's
the issue with the language barrier so
and so forth so it's it's quite simply
just blunt instructions can you follow
this follow that i want you to do so
well
i know that chef i know you've put so
much into this and you know throughout
the whole process you've been so
supportive and you know everything
you've said i have taken on board
right well done
[Music]
some people may look at me and think i'm
cocky i'm arrogant i'm unapproachable i
mean chef's obviously got the impression
of me but
i'm not like that at all it's just
throughout the years
we've always
we've always been knocked
for our approach by people within our
industry
for
you know pushing the barrier not being
you know go with the flow of what's
available what's out there
and
taking the easier approach and i guess
it's a
defense mechanism that we've built up
i'm not here to offend anyone i didn't
want to offend chef but this doesn't
mean a lot to me
the fact that i was able to cook in the
kitchen today
have my
my rest my menu item on on
chef's menu card
you know that's
that has overwhelmed me and you know
i'm not a man i'm not a very emotional
person but
yeah it's
it's been very tough for me today and i
didn't want it to end up this way
only one russian can go through to my
grand final and tonight who stays and
who goes
is my decision
right now i'm facing an impossible task
honestly who's got the edge
[Music]
i don't know right now
[Music]
welcome back to royal hospital road
i'm about to choose one restaurant to go
through to the grand final of my
competition
will it be santa maria del sir or la san
in very different ways they are both
exceptional restaurants
before i make my choice i'm going to
taste the dishes cooked here tonight by
ernesto and aktar
right santa maria
lamb kebab doesn't sound the most
glamorous but it looks fantastic a nice
potato salad purple potatoes
and waxy new potatoes so with the mint
chutney
wow
the mint chunk is made with rice wine
vinegar jalapeno pepper really nice and
vibrant and sort of wakes up that lamb
i was a little bit worried when i first
saw the dish in terms of the simplicity
factor but
delicious in terms of taste lovely warm
potato salad stunning kebab and the most
amazing mint chutney yeah
brilliant that was it close your eyes
and wow this is heaven absolutely
delicious
lesson presentation quite fiddly
yeah you'd expect that from
rectang
wow absolutely phenomenal anyone can
cook lamb like that but not anyone can
make a gravy as delicious as that you
taste it and it blows your mind away i
mean it's just phenomenal i mean
absolutely delicious
talented talented cook without a shadow
of doubt unfortunately the biggest
problem is himself and i'm faced with a
tough tough choice la san they they they
hit the heights but boy do they come
down crashing big time but the food up
there is extraordinary when it gets
there santa maria
consistently good every day haven't put
a foot out of place yet this is a very
tough call
so it's the moment of truth
two outstanding restaurants but only one
can win a place in the grand final
okay
first of all to all of you yeah
seriously well done i really mean that
really well done
absolutely phenomenal okay
santa maria
i love the passion
absolutely love it and it's a breath of
fresh air to see
not just the chefs but the service
at such an exciting level everything you
touch
is about passion and it shows across the
board those 20
main courses were phenomenal the mint
sauce was exceptional
the texture of the lamb yeah absolutely
delicious
you weren't even working on charcoal and
you still managed
to put that flavor in it really well
done
weaknesses
got slightly nervous when i saw just
three things on the plate
could you put something else on there in
terms of a grilled vegetable or a salad
could you push the boundary out even
further
i gave you the perfect opportunity today
to really show off
i thought the dish was outstanding thank
you you delivered
could you have done any more
who knows
lasagne
the first minute
i walked into that restaurant i was
excited and blown away by the level of
ambition you're pushing the boundaries
out
like no other restaurants
within your category unique flavor i
mean very unique flavor and you don't
really expect to find that little bit of
magic there that's like wow
give me more of that
lowe's
when you get excited
about reaching the top
it can't be done
individually
it has to be done with a team
that's not one in the kitchen one in the
dining room that is everybody
you have to take everybody to where you
want to go
now there's only one restaurant that's
going through
to the final
[Music]
this has been the toughest decision so
far let me tell you that
and i really mean that
the restaurant that's going through the
final
[Music]
is lasanne
[Music]
now
let the food do the talking okay that
this was unique
really well done thank you okay
and i can't wait to see how you perform
in the final
i won't disappoint jeff
you and your team
yeah yeah well done
really well done congratulations and you
come here you ah well done absolutely
brilliant thank you
that was a difficult decision for me and
you are one talented chef never forget
that it is a bit of a shock still is a
bit of a shock and i mean i'm still
still sinking in so
on to the final and
and and beyond yeah
just looking forward to getting back and
uh celebrating with the team
i know you see him this emotion
both restaurants produce food worthy of
raw hostel road tonight i'm very proud
of them but ultimately i saw real
flashes of genius in the dishes akhtar
created
lassen has a potential to be one of the
great indian restaurants and actor
thorough deserves his place in the final
i think everyone will tell you up in
i've been quite horrible to be around
because this means a hell of a lot
and
a dream come true doesn't sum up
what this means to me